on
foreign
12 to 30. so i believe
we've got to dial in through andrew
davis from bradford
andrew good afternoon hi good afternoon
everybody good afternoon chair
let's see okay so we've got
um we've got three agenda items today
chair we've got items
12 and 13. um they're all
sort of intrinsically linked so
is it possible to take take those three
together
or would you rather me keep them
separately
i'm i'm happy to take your items one
after the other
yes that's fine okay thank you thank you
chair
they all sort of form part of the update
the update report
um as it is so um
if if members could turn to page 15 of
the progress
progress report that sets out the uh
the sort of the high level messages
pages 15 and 16.
so the the key messages are that we've
we've started our
um financial statements ordered we
started that back in
in mid-june and that's been completely
completed
remotely as per as per last year
and this is looking to address the the
the risks that we set out an
anti-audit plan that was presented back
in back in march by
julie and so in terms of an update
we're making we're making really good
progress across all the areas in terms
of our origin of the financial
statements
um effectively the false the full
site visit where we've got the team all
working on the on the accounts is due to
finish by the end of this week and
however there will be some areas of work
that we need to
um that where we're still waiting for
every responses and we've still got some
work at our end actually to tidy up as
well
which i'll go on to in a little bit more
detail as part of
which effectively was a gender item
12 or 13 in terms of our sort of
updating out the audit findings
to date
so in in terms of in terms of in terms
of where we are
um so we've completed
uh a substantial amount of the work um
our significant risks that we set out in
the audit plan were around management
override of control
which links into our journals work and
our work around estimations
we're hoping to get that work completed
by the end of this week
and today we found no issues that we
need to bring to your attention as those
charged with governance
our our pensions work our work on that
significant estimation
that is within the within the financial
statements again is in progress
um and and again today we've got no
issues that we need to bring
to your attention and that's one way
if you remember back to previous years
we always get a letter of assurance from
the auditors of the devon county pension
fund
and and that is something that's that's
going to be we're going to be waiting
for before we can actually
finalize that piece of work anyway but
we're hoping to get
the bulk of that done um so that we're
just waiting for that piece of assurance
before we can issue out
opinion property planted equipment um
again is the other is the other
significant risk
bigger big number in the accounts
obviously a lot of judgments and
estimations that go into pulling that
number together
we've we've completed um
a lot of that work and we're looking to
get the bulk of that done by the end of
this week
um however we we have got a few queries
that we need to pick up with a valuer
and i think the value is off on leave
now until september so we'll have to
pick up some of those within when it
when he returns
but again nothing on any of those areas
to date that
of any of any concern that needs to be
done to your attention
there's a there's a number of areas
where we've got bits of work to complete
um where we sort of we've raised queries
on
and and where we've got to kind of just
um
finish our procedures in those areas uh
some of those the more notable ones
around sort of
some of the grant income um some of the
the receivables of the debtors financial
instruments
and the council tax side of the
collection fund so those are some of the
areas where
we we've just got to find final hours
out finalize our procedures
albeit everything everything has been
started
so the plan going forward is
that we that we get the bulk of the work
done by the end of this week
we then look to finalize all the things
we can
as soon as possible with the exception
of that i set out that we obviously got
the
the pension fund auditors letter and
some of the crews we've got to pick up
around
pp can i just interject there from the
auditor's letter are granted the
auditors
for the pension plan still yes yes but
it's it's a separate
it's a separate audit team it might be a
separate audit team but i'm sure
an email to your colleagues would secure
that quickly
yeah that they have the audit is in
progress
um and it won't be finalized for um
for a few weeks um in fact probably
probably a month or so
so it we always end up with you know
it's a substantial audit
the the audit of the devon county
pension fund
um and and it's not just storage that
would be weighted for that length of
assurance it would be
other other districts across devon so
they can't issue that letter to us until
they've completed their work
and at the moment they haven't completed
that work so they can't issue that later
because until they've until they've
tested the um
the amounts within the within the
pension fund
they can't issue those assurances to us
and that that underpins a lot of the
information that
appears in torridge's financial
statements
it's just this is the second year
running this has happened and i would
thought
learnings from the first year would have
indicated that there's
a better way of doing it it could be
done the other way around the audits of
the pension fund before the local
authority
they well they are they are started um
they're always our priority because for
that reason
but they are quite complex and they're
quite they're quite big audits
so they always they always sort of
they always go on but hopefully we can
they can get it signed off in time
because
obviously the you know the deadline for
us actually signing off the accounts
isn't
until until later in the year anyway so
as long as we get the
assurances by then and i would hope by
the time we issue our already finance
report
for the september uh audit and
governance committee then we would have
those assurances and we'd be in a
position to move
straight to being able to sign the
opinion um
is that okay chair i i mean i i
understand the comment you're making
yeah i'm i'm satisfied with the answer
yes
thank you uh so we
as i said out there we'd look to report
the findings of the audit
on the uh in the to the september or in
governance committee um
and hopefully but by then we'll have the
responses from the
valuer and also the responses from the
pension fund the pension fund auditor
on this on page 15 we will
also set out our value for money um
element of our work now i think as we've
set out earlier in the year
there's been quite a substantial change
to the to the amount of work we have to
do on value for money
it moves away from an opinion now
because of the change in the code that
the nao have issued
rather than being just arrangements are
adequate and we always focused on a
on a on a what we deem to be from our
planning
the uh significant risk of weakness
and it was always around financial
sustainability to now where we have to
give a commentary
across all areas of the council in terms
of covering
the financial sustainability governance
and and securing the threes with with an
element of covert for this year thrown
in in terms of
how that's impacted on arrangements so
that's quite a
that's quite a significant undertaking
and we we've
we've completed that for our nhs
audience now and actually that
that is quite a big significant piece of
work
um in terms of those changes now that
what that introduced was
it got rid of the annual audit letter
which was our summary of our
our work throughout the year and
introduce the annual auditor's report
which gives this vfm this value for
money commentary
now what the nao have done this year is
in recognition of
covid and the impact that's having on
sort of preparers but also
in terms of like auditors and being able
to deliver this this increased work
they've decoupled the deadlines between
the deadline for signing off financial
statements
and um and in
issuing the annual auditor's reports
so the the the latest guidance that they
ann area have set out is that the
the deadline for the aars the annual
launchers report
is three months from the date of signing
the opinion
now we would hope not to be using that
that time but that's just to kind of
make you aware of kind of
those that sort of almost like that
decoupling because what they're trying
to focus on is that they know that
there's a challenge there in terms of
delivering
financial statements audits and that is
their priority
so they to to free up to free up
capacity and allow that work to be done
in terms of the financial statements
they've they've moved those two apart or
be
we'll be aiming to get our value for
money work completed
um by by september and that that work is
currently
in progress in terms of the uh the
document reviews that
underpin that work i see from
um the statement you're proposing to
charge
nine thousand pounds for this um value
for money audit
what actually does this entail you know
i've listened to what you've said
but what does this entail secondly to it
what benefit district council is there
for this work you know obviously
when an auditor goes in it's a two-way
process
um you're looking to check that
everything
is above board and straight and we are
an ongoing concern
but also there's got to be some added
value for the people being audited
so what exactly do you add
to torch district councils understanding
when they receive this value from money
documents
that's quite an interesting question
actually because i mean
from the work that we did in in the nhs
just at a really high level
when we when we pulled all the work
together and so because we looked at um
you know financial sustainability the
governance and we have to get that
that baseline because there are areas
that we we perhaps haven't looked at in
the past
so we have to get that sort of baseline
as to what's going on and how things
how things work in detail at those sort
of governance levels
but also in terms of you know the 3e
stuff looking down at what drives costs
and
how the council get that understanding
and the benchmarking and the
and the wider the wider things that that
could be done we
we we've completed um some some
benchmarking which actually helps us to
inform that three
that three side of things so the economy
the efficiency and effectiveness
and that's what we'll be using to to to
look at particular areas and challenge
particular areas in terms of
how how things are doing and then
off the back of that hopefully make some
recommendations for improvement
as to kind of how how how things could
be done
how could things could be done better
going forward um
and then the other feedback that i've
had when i presented the aars to nhs
bodies
is that actually what they found was
because it's been such a challenging
year and this is particularly in
in this year was actually having
everything in one place as to kind of
what's happened and
you know how things have changed and how
things have been brought together
actually members of the of the boards
and the committees are actually feeding
back and saying
it's really nice just to see that
snapshot as well you know that
that has really added value to them in
terms of bringing all those
assurances and everything into one place
okay so it's what drives costs
benchmarking and recommendations to
improvement going forward so that's what
i'll be able to read into the letter
when it comes
to us yes
thank you
so so the the other on
page 16 it i think you just mentioned
the
sort of the increase in the fees and
obviously we've got
the uh the audit scope letter which is
which is another agenda item
um which is on
i think page
trying to find the page for the for the
scope
the scope letter
i think it's on page 207
so this the fee letter that starts on
207 at the time we wrote the audit plan
that information wasn't available
because we hadn't undertaken an
assessment as to kind of how much
the the value for money and the changes
to the uh the auditing standards in year
around sort of iso 540 and that
increased level of
challenge around estimations was going
to impact that was undertaken at a
national
at a national level to make sure that
everything was treated consistently
across across the board and then we've
so we've issued the scope letter now
which effectively
updates the audit plan in terms of those
in terms of those audit fees
um so the the main points to consider
are obviously
in terms of previous years when we've
had those increases because of the
frc challenge around sort of property
plant and equipment and the additional
work that's needed there
that work still remains required so that
so those fees
sort of roll forward into the next year
and then we've got the increase in terms
of the value for money and then the
increase in terms of changes to doors
and standards
the main one being the iso 540 which i
mentioned
in terms of the estimations and the
amount of work that is required to
to to address that and it i suppose it
should be noted that
all of all of those fees are subject to
psa approval and we're obviously
also aware that mhs
clg have obviously issued um
15 million of additional funding to to
to help councils in terms of the
additional costs
in relation to into relation to the
audit fees which
which should be paid within 2122 but can
be used to offset the 22-21
additional costs
i think and and then let's get just
going back to the
update report there's a there's a couple
of there's a couple of
um there's a sector update in there
which is there from the members
information
um but i think the key the key ones that
i wasn't going to go into them in any
great detail but the the two main ones
are around the um on pages 18 to 29
um we've obviously got the psa
um i've actually started the
reappointment process
so in terms of like food from 22 23 is
the end of the current contract
and they'll be looking to reallocate
those contracts but
you know within that slide it talks it
talks very much about
you know looking at making sure that the
you know that the fees are
are appropriate and making sure that
this
doesn't you know there's enough capacity
within the system to be able to deliver
the audits on a timely basis
and this all links back to the redmond
review which which is obviously
identified challenges
um challenges in terms of audits and
and that side of things the other one is
on
on page 20 which is which is quite an
interesting read and that's around the
lessons learned and some of the
some of the uh summaries of the
public interest reports that have been
issued in terms of
some of the failings of other councils
and where potentially
um members can can can have a read and
learn from where where are the people
who have made mistakes
i i'll pause their chair i'm
conscious the fact that that was kind of
a little bit all over the place because
i've tried to cover
i've tried to cover three three agenda
items
all in one but they were all they were
all quite linked in terms of order
delivery and then the link
to um sort of a
sort of the additional fees um and
the audit progress in terms of how we go
forward
from here so i'll pause there for any
questions
[Music]
you're in your fifth week of doing this
audit so you're
anticipating six weeks work
um how would you say the audit is
compared with the amount of information
you're asking this year with previous
years
in in terms of our request for
information chair
yes
um i think i think
largely largely similar
um i mean david might
sort of have a view i think you know we
as auditors we have we have
we have to be very mindful of like you
know in terms of professional skepticism
and
things like so we always we would never
we would never look to do exactly what
we did the year before
because that you know that that change
in
intact slightly obviously um
you know that that's part of part of our
professional skepticism um so there are
areas where we probably
request more but then there's somewhere
actually we've probably requested less
so i'd say
out of balance the requests of
information have
largely been the same probably a slight
increase because
you know things are always kind of
ramping up in terms of
um in terms of requests for example
you know in previous years we've we've
had the frc have really challenged
around
property planted equipment and and that
process but also the
the pension fund side of things that was
always their flavor now
this year the findings and what they've
been coming out with and issuing
further guidance on is around journals
testing
so i would say that is definitely an
area where our sample sizes around
journals
have gone up um but but again that is in
response to
um in response to sort of
into challenging that area and actually
you know trying to respond
and to to remain in line with best
practice
so you wouldn't be looking with
sort of an enhanced degree of skepticism
about
sort of assets being the minuses of
council would be saying right okay
um prove that you have your council
offices existing things like that
you would be accepting that you're
looking at a local authority
which is well grounded rather than a
company which may be
some degree or
we would we would test existence of
assets or be
under our approach we can we can roll
forward some of that for a three year
period
but we would still you know for example
we we know quite a few councils are
actually undercovered
they've actually taken an undertaking
like a rationalization of their
their properties because they're saying
well actually before we potentially had
three buildings we don't need three
buildings now
because people are working from home for
x days of week
so with that in mind we have to then
take a step back and we have to look at
it and think well
okay if if we don't live locally
we need to make sure that those those
things still exist
so um but but there are areas that we
can
roll forward for example like around
ownership where we've where we've
tested deeds in the past and we've got
no indication that those
the you know the the council no longer
owns the building
then obviously we can use and make
reference to that that information
okay so if there are no further
questions
um this report was promoting so
we duly note your items
6 6 12 and 13
13. so we consider items 6
12 and 13 julie noted
okay andrew thank you very much for
diving into us
thank you
[Music]
right we will now go back to the agenda
and
item seven with ordered reports issued
today to page
31 to 36 and
these have been
um good afternoon hopefully you can hear
me okay
um yes i'm going to give you an update
on this on this on this paper so it's on
from page 31. this is our
standard update of work we've delivered
since the last
audit committee as as you can see we
have
um five audit reports contained in the
update
but we've disputed copies of the full
reports
already to the committee um appendix a
contains a summary of the um of the
audits
um i'll provide some sort of um
some some thoughts from from our view on
on the work
um as you can see we've we've given
uh two audits um substantial assurance
and free reasonable assurance um so just
um going through each of them
um so safeguarding so um obviously we
looked at arrangements for
safeguarding a very important area and
we thought that
uh controls were effective but
um we agreed recommendations relating to
um undertaking the um the section 11
audit
um and also reviewing the safeguarding
policy
which had not been done for for some
years
on um equality and diversity
again uh we thought um overall
arrangements were in place effective to
promote equality and diversity
in the workforce but we thought that
more needs to be done to consider how
how the council could increase workforce
diversity um we also
noted that having more complete
information on
on i-trent will help support this sort
of consideration
and sub support this is a better
awareness of whether
you know the diversity or non-diversity
of workforce
um and also we know there's a need to
undertake the annual equality and
diversity report
and for everyone officers and and
members
to undertake the equality and diversity
training
on um housing benefit and council tax
support again this is another
substantial assurance we provided
again uh we thought there was a strong
control framework in place
um and this was despite the uh
significant additional demands
on the on the team due to the 19
emergency and additional work they've
had to take on
um one one impact has been to
increase time to process claims
but we think that quality checks have
been maintained
um despite that and also collection
rates are
are reasonably um quite quite good
um risk management um
so this this obviously reporters of
particular interest
in relation to government statement um
broadly we were content with the risk
management framework
uh we thought that there needs to be
more conscious review
by the risk management group um
and also um more considerate
consideration about
operational risks i think last year um
they tended um uh because of the
emergency um they weren't sort of mapped
out for the i understand that this year
they are being
uh agreed um and that should support
a bit more consideration of of bottom-up
risks and so on
um and then finally a car parking
um a couple of things firstly sort of we
i
identified the need for better
monitoring of
penalty charge notice collection um
without that monitoring there's a risk
of
and possible lots of future write-offs
when
the notices aren't collecting collected
and and and then secondly
um we sort of highlighted the perhaps
more consideration about the
risk assessment of the health and safety
of of parking
service staff when they're about their
duties
so um that's that's given you a sort of
a summary of
of of the work um but happy to take um
any questions
right we've been circulating these
reports
as they've been done um
i just see if any of the community have
any comments to make
no videos so we note
the reports that you sent thank you very
much for the time
okay this afternoon and
we will move on to the next item
which is the
annual internal audit report
which is item 8 pages 37-51
and rob is taking this one thank you ron
thank you for having me members so this
is the annual
internal report uh looking backwards
from last year 2021
um and i'll just do a quick page turn
through the uh from the portfolio
um i think the uh the first thing we'll
be doing page 39 is
obviously covered on an impact on our
work last year that's on uh some audits
a planned
smartphone plan was adjusted to the year
to take the countdown
i think it's
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
should give you a decent level of
assurance
again put in that box there uh
[Music]
uh yes there's a few comments there
about the impact of code
um just moving through the report on
page
42. there's a table there just
summarizing the assurance opinions
completed
[Music]
should keep you assured things work um
and for us really that the work is
always um
important we find things that management
can respond to those issues
i think we've got a good relationship
with management
that at do respect the findings of the
work and recommendations that we make
do get implemented and i know their
officers track the implementation of
those recommendations
so that's a good feedback loop going
through we find things bring your
attention you get that kind of assurance
that things are taken seriously and
addressed um towards the bottom of page
42
you will see that default of work so i'm
really just highlighting to you
that there was a number of what is
[Music]
[Music]
can i just ask
[Music]
as we always do really um we always take
a plan to just communicate about
february march time
but we always present the right and as
you expect us to do if we knew risks
come in
let go of it so we've got these
[Music]
there's a section on floor prevention
and detection
um
[Music]
again we have minimum levels of reported
through
other councils here and internationally
we've seen some
key statistics in particular because
so yeah that's an enlarged for us um
toys to be to be mindful to be
uh to be cautious and to have those good
controls in place
but we traditionally have seen low
levels of floor
coming from the systems here and i'm
sure that's doing due
in the large manners operating system
i think that's really all the key things
that's going to bring you with your
attention in that chair
um back on page
15 if we're looking at numbers
and again even though it's harder and
greater
so that's probably a very decent cancel
through the report
um i'll probably explain the key things
i'd want to bring to potentially a
committee
i'm very happy to take any questions and
they will detail that
any questions
i just got one actually it's to do the
19th grant assurance
um you've given a reasonable assurance
in your risk opinion and the overall
opinion trying to report application is
substantial
i'd expect the two to be the same but if
you
suggested elaborate on that yeah i
apologize i think there's a we we
changed our assurance opinion warranty
during the year
[Music]
substantial assurances
[Music]
if you wanted to compare uh work say on
creditors within the local authority
in theory of all those surprises adopted
this different
could um
that's fine um so if we have no further
comments
i will ask the committee to note
that report so it's to be noted
and we will move on to item number nine
which is the draft annual government
statement
page 1571 and
the reports begin by the service
improvement officer
[Music]
so over to you chris
[Music]
such an appointment
[Music]
of curbs and councils governance
arrangements and also the
instruction of the new financial
marketing account
um i took the opportunity for this new
guidance to actually have a look at our
kind of full review of our report to the
ags
[Music]
and it's probably a better governance
technology in my opinion
[Music]
um page 16
still provides um a schematic
somewhere's not goodness arrangements on
one page just a kind of
full picture of our government's
regulation on one page
everything's involved then the next two
pages
61 and 62 um symbolize the impact of
curving acting
on government's arrangements and i think
[Music]
64.
[Music]
um
[Music]
here the next page page 66
sets out the role of the chief executive
officer
um responsibly in place
and making sure things happen any
weaknesses
[Music]
in terms of our financial accounts our
governance measures and this management
arrangements
then 69 audits and what's just been
through that
[Music]
gets challenged and then finally page 71
is an action plan and this year i've
kind of identified three
three governor's weaknesses which i
think needs to be found invented by
the first one is the um acid magic plan
which
expired in 2017 this is actually last
year's
um hsn didn't get completed
last couple of three or four years of
that people who
thought he was supposed to be doing this
this year the chief
putting a new management structure in
that department to split the roles
of the state manager and projects
manager and
the new estate has been appointed and
responsible for kind of getting this
done this year
certainly by march 2022
second one members will be familiar with
the leisure contract
and we're moving the arrangements for
that because arrangements of that
achievement let's make sure that happens
by march 2022.
the third one is going back to the
payment of the purpose plans for the
paid up 40 million pounds
in questions a bit of time um and there
are a lot of reasons why that's maybe
people shouldn't have been transparent
showing that the action takes place
[Music]
the owners and it made a little bit
difficult because multiple donors
actually live abroad
they're contesting that they owe the
money but at some point
we'll curtail our action and pass on
today to the department of business and
enterprise to
further the recovery process
so this report has been signed off by
the committee september one of the
accounts
just can't which has today committed to
ask any questions
or because any changes to the documents
do any members have any questions
no no questions
thank you very much for that um tour of
the
document and i could say this is very
clear
it's a good movement to carry forward
into the future
thank you very much thank you so much
that report and we go on to
item number 10 which is weightless and
non-compliance
procedural rules page 72 82
and we're receiving a report from the
section 1.1 officer
david if you'd like to carry on yes
thank you chair
um just the basis of the repository
we're supposed to uh officers follow
our financial and contract procedurals
however there's always going to be
occasion when that's as difficult or not
practical
and what this report is just outlines
the occasions on which we've actually
issued away from our contractors
and generally contracted procedurals is
depending on the value of something that
would be serviced with purchasing we
should
have a tender so
if we move to the key point as you move
to
page 73 you've got there the number of
waivers by
year so even though indeed financially
2020 2020-21 we had six waivers six
times occasions we
moved away from our financial systemic
financial procedures
and contract procedure rules i mean as
you can see that's probably that's
probably the lowest [ __ ] that's the
lowest 2012 person so it actually means
that officers are applying
to our contracts and procedure rules and
sticking to them from
very limited circumstances the six
reasons that the waivers were issued and
the details for running the report
we've always got going through that list
i would see rio
in the high street the street wardens
the summer safe scheme sport for leisure
and perhaps the rough sleeper initiative
we're only directly creative related to
the corporate pandemic in our response
to them
so it's really that we're not really if
you've been waivers from our financial
procedure rules
during the course of the year other than
the ones that really been a direct
result
of the pandemic um
i can't say i sit here this time this
year we wouldn't have a similar number
of them being put
because always things arise you know
numbers we're wearing like with leisure
we've got an urgent need to review our
ledger option and we
um waived our procedurals to employ a
company called lsc to do that that's the
reason why we've already done that
um i've got nothing more to answer the
report because the actual individual
waivers are contained within the report
is just to highlight to members that
we've done six waivers
it's the lowest we've done now for the
best part of ten years and given that
we're in a pandemic with
different demands upon the council i
don't think it was too bad a performance
overall
right thank you very much david um
yeah it's all straightforward the
reasons are written into the report
so does anybody have any questions asked
no so i would duly note
that item and move on to item
number 11. the presentation of the draft
financial statement is on page to 212.
and back to you back to you david
i think you'll be pleased to know that
go through page my page on 115 pages
accounts so this is
probably the most challenging
presentation i've tried to make i've
tried to explain the final account and
i'm probably going to fail without being
honest so what are the state of accounts
well first off the backward look
it's the position financial position the
council is on 31st of march
and we're now already in july so it's at
that point in time
there's a little bit of looking forward
in terms of the narrative in terms of
looking at
our financial sustainability going
forward but largely
it's a backwards-looking document is
complex
and it requires translation perfectly
honest
they're far related on a different basis
than the management accounts reported
in the qbi to intimate world human
scrutiny
so they're on a different basis in our
management accounts which we make our
decisions on
it's subject to external audits it must
provide assurance to members that the
figures presented are a fair
representation of the council's
financial position
and i think the chair asked grant
thompson about the
level of information providing assured
members it's quite substantial
um so also the external audit were
provided directly
insurance regarding the efficiency of
control and robustness of the finance
and the last one is actually the most
important one the devil is actually in
the detail
and it's an untrained eye that'll be
quite difficult to um
pick out that next slide please
so this is why this might have been a
bit ambitious i'm going to
extend to explain the four key
statements from the statement of
accounts the
comprehensive income expenditure account
you
would call that the ie if we're in a
normal company but we're not we're a
local clarity
the movement in the reserve statement
the balance sheet
and the cash flow statements
so these are extracts from the funds
statement of accounts
so we break it down into our reporting
segments the chief exec as an area of
budget
the head of legal governance somebody
it's the finance management southwestern
budget
community and other which is i am the
crematorium
so the 9.8 million represents the cost
of providing the council services
however includes they include income and
expenditure
and some grants which are expected
directly to the individual services some
grants are treated as funded some go
directly to individual services
but it also includes depreciation the
impairment of assets which are not
included you
[Music]
and then you've got over operating
expenditure well basically
that's the parish precepts that's the
money that would pay over to all those
talent parish councils in the bay
and there's some quirky little things in
there like a notional figure for the
admin of the pension service
and again in the revaluation of the
disposal so we sold an asset for
more than it was in our books that extra
money
goes in there so to finance and
investment expenditure
includes actual cash payments relating
to servicing loans
physical crap cash pertaining to short
term on shots and treasury deposits
as well as non-cash items such as the
net interest on the defined pension
liability that's
basically an accounting adjustment from
the pension fund
the taxation and non-specific grants
that's where
basically that's our income so that
includes the grants we get from
government
the money we get from council tax and
what do we get from business rates
and these are not credited to individual
services they're treated as the income
of the council as a whole
next slide please so i'm sorry go back
please if that's possible um
is it tom sorry some apologies
so we're reporting that a surplus
deficit on the provision of services
of 1.620 1.571
x factors
and then we come into the real dark
cards
so essentially we say we had a surplus
of 1.571
and we suddenly ended up with a deficit
of 7.7 million
and the reason being is the main thing
is that the read
measurements of the net defined benefit
levels this is basically the movement of
the pension liability
in this case it's an adverse movement
it's not a real
cost to the council we haven't paid 9.3
million to devon county council
don't pay that in this adverse movement
rates to primary to future assumptions
regarding long-term inflation
the pension actuary is bound when
calculating the pension liability to
assume the return on investment
at a corporate fund rate in reality the
pension fund would expect to
make returns significantly in excess of
this which was the accounting rules on
the pension
in long-term investor return long-term
investments has to be a corporate bond
rate
they would always anticipate to get more
than that
so long term inflation i think you could
actually hire a lower left i can't
remember the top edges at the moment
but basically we're going to put for our
books and recognize that the pension
deficit has moved by nine million pounds
like i say no cash has left the council
next slide please
i don't even know why i included this
slide because i don't understand it to
be perfectly honest with you
the efa what that's supposed to do is
supposed to explain why we go from our
management account
to the surplus and it's only not it's
only understood really by
accountability personality so the left
hand column
is our management account position is
zero
what we mean by that that's zero we put
monies to reserve so we're balanced
after we've put money to reserves and
the next two columns
are putting through the various
adjustments which don't go through the
management account so these would be
things like depreciation compartment
valuation
assets payment of the parish precepts
and
then it says local government statute
applies included just between funding
and accounting basis so these are things
where
we've got a deficit on the pension fund
and we just create the reserve these are
account adjustments that only happen at
a local authority level
to come back to that surplus so i've
really put that in really to say
it's almost unexplainable so you go
through the management accounting
position which is balanced after we put
money to reserves
you go through all these dark hearts
essentially so things that don't happen
in the commercial world to a large
degree
things like straight and reserved
because if you've got a pension
liability
to come back to the figure that's
reported on the cis which is the
comprehensive income expenditure account
and the next slide please
right movement in the reserve statement
so i won't go through the detail of this
the
key things to note here reserves are
split into two categories
usable and non-usable i mean really
simple serves
their usable reserve actually equates to
cash
if we've got usable reserves of 15
million pounds 16 million pounds
generally we'll have approximately that
amount of money in the bank account
that that's in essence unusual reserves
but they're equated are created by
local government accounting convention
um so that would be where we create a
reserve to
meet the increased cost of the deficit
in one pension fund for example
so yeah you've got usable reserves for
2021 to exit
increased by six side eight six point
eight million however the devil's in the
details i said earlier
this does not mean the council has 6.8
million to use as it wishes
and i'll come to that later so that's
why it's such a
central challenge for you as members of
this committee to actually understand
their accounts
come the next slide please why don't we
create
songs
probably the easiest one to understand
is a balance sheet in simple terms this
details the assets of the council
our landlord buildings our investment
properties our vehicles
our cash debtors the money is owed to
the council
and the liabilities account both the
council such as creditors
other liabilities such as the pension
fund deficit and outstanding loans
and the net assets of the council are
backed by by reserves both
usable and unusable that's fine please
i would say that the balance sheet is
there's one statement you could look at
in the account
that would look recognizable with the
company's accounts
the cash flow so what the cash flow
statement saying you start off with the
surplus that you reported on the
provision of services
that's what surplus did we get on doing
planning
building control refuse collection etc
but
taking into account things like
appreciation
and then what we do we adjust it through
other things there's nothing to do with
caps such as deep appreciation
impairment on assets movement in the
pension liability
and the movement on the creditor and
debtor balances
and then we deduct capital items such as
the proceeds from sale of assets and
capital grants credited to this
capacion of services so
we will sell an asset during the course
of the year and get cash ins that's
cash but in terms of the revenue account
that never appeared
it's not a revenue item and then we
deduct
items such as purchasing fixed assets so
that doesn't go when we purchase a fixed
asset like a vehicle
or some land that doesn't go through the
revenue cap but still means cash has
left the council's coffers so to speak
and then we deduct financing taxes
repayment shots and
long term debt these are cash items
which are not included in the surface on
the provision of services as well
so what i'm really trying to say the
surplus that's reported on this from the
comprehensive income expense capital
staff
that is not the difference between the
cash going out and that's coming in
it has to be just difficult um
and actually the main thing to know is
there's been there's actually an
increase in our cash flows five and a
half 5.6 million during the year that's
the main point to know the cash flows
down what did the class move by
next slide please
so what are the key highlights from the
state of calc
i'll be honest i'm not sure the late
first looking at catholics pick these
out
so you may look at the balance sheet and
say well as those creditors have gone up
they've gone to 12.6 million and they're
only 3.4 million last year
doesn't mean we'll stop paying our
invoices in a commercial company if you
saw creditors going up short-term credit
is going up
you'd be concerned you'd be thinking the
company is having cash flow difficulties
and not paying its creditors and its
financial position is worsening
but this actually just reflects the
money that we owe to government for
business support
they're not actually distributed yet
short-term betters
they've increased to 8.9 from 2.9 that
doesn't mean we've been a bit neglectful
in chasing people who always money
this move reflects our business rate
preception to central government devon
county council in the fire over the
council for business rating
that we paid on account based on a
budget before the pandemic
rather than the actual business rates
that we collected
that's what i said before about the
usable reserves that the devil's in the
detail
in that reserves they've moved up to
15.7
versus 9 million last year doesn't mean
we've got more and money set aside to do
we wish we've set aside best part 4
million to be our share of the loss on
the nfdr collection fund because we
didn't collect as much business rates
last year because the government
gave extended retail relief however they
compensated the council by grant
and we've put 0.8 million aside into
reserve with respect to
covered grants that we've received in
advance so we've had some money from the
government we've received the grants in
advance
the key point actually this is the real
point
for the council in its day-to-day
activities going forward into 2021-22 is
we've actually set 1.6 million pounds
into reserve for leisure
and the contribution to the deficit on
the capital programme etc so actually
the financial performance of last year
has allowed the council to put 1.6
million pounds away
backed by cash into its coffers which he
can deal with next year and what it
wants to do and we've had expat leisure
being one of the big
things you want to deal with um the
pension fund
deficits move by 10 as i alluded to
but what you don't know is that this is
the best part four to two million
thousand of expenditure income
is not visible in our state of account
because this relates to business support
grants where the council acted as an
agent of the government and the
accountant will say
you don't include that into your books
if you only act as an agent of the
government
so the vast majority of what we actually
basically spent last year isn't actually
in our state
because it's um just acting as those
actors and agents of the government
next time please
oh sorry just any questions if anybody's
getting questions
right and casa buschmann david the
1.6 million with the natives is there
any possibility that a portion of that
um the reason we created a surplus of
1.6 million is primarily we've got some
grants we've got about 1.1 million pound
worth of crowds from central government
just general culvert support and we got
some new burgers from about 370 000
pounds that's what
administering the business support
grants and we've got some what's called
fees and compensation i think about 390
000
from the government so that is our money
that's our money we're talking about
what we have to pay back to the because
they've actually given us business
support
to pay on to businesses and we don't pay
it onto businesses that's what we have
to give back and that's what we've
accounted for in our state
of accounts
[Music]
it does but looking at the national
financial situation clearly you know the
country's in up to
two and hundreds of billions of pounds
and i can just see a situation
developing where
the government are going to be looking
nationally all around the country
looking at
individual authorities that have a
sharpness or have
spare cash somewhere and they're going
to one way or another they're going to
try and get their
their clothes into that money whether
it's taking it directly off
you or not giving you grant funding for
other things
you know it's you can see exactly where
i'm coming from
yeah i'm not sure i personally could
give an answer i don't know the thoughts
of risky the um chancellor
but um there is a danger the government
looks at in that reserves this year
i think the council started the moment
in the day but just explained
that to the reserves we have a lot of
them that's
because we've got to pay back so the
deficit on the business straight
collection funds so they're gonna it's
gonna be a difficult exercise for them
because
the email obviously is so strange this
year
any other comments from councillors um
i'm just going to put a challenge
question to you um
we heard earlier the impact of coded 19
on governance arrangements
and i'm just going to quote a piece the
last reduction in some of the council's
income streams
added to the additional costs associated
with keeping communities safe
and local business solvent resulted in a
major
financial burden for the council during
2021 the statutory finance officer
continually assessed
the impact of code 19 on the council's
long-term financial viability
and provided regular updates to members
are you happy on going that we're in a
good position
as we could be at this stage um yes
we do discuss something in risk later on
is this microphone on by the way
i just relayed that you're affirmative
yes
[Music]
that actually totally has some unique
features
in terms of the impact of colby one was
that uh
our planet england was never never seen
the likes of this and probably next to
the light
again the car parking income bounced
back
from the first three months from the
first very strong lockdown
we absorbed all the work extra work was
given so the new version of something
that we got
essentially was additional and it was
very little additional
essentially um when i'm going to part
two i'll allude to something in part two
okay thank you very much i'm satisfied
with the answer
thank you right so
again we note this report
thank you very much david thank you for
very good
we have dealt with enough item 12
findings we now move on to
the forward plan item 14 so we go to
page
219
david would you like to talk through
them
right another problem
wishing the main main thing
[Music]
on the forward plan is that the next
meeting hopefully that's when we'll have
the accounts actually signed off
um because the deadline is actually
the patreon the date yes it is correct
the date is the 30th
we need to have you signed up by the end
of september
um
yes it's going to turn to
robbie to see if uh partnership
could get some advice to assess the
effectiveness of the
audit committee can we assist on that
which sets up the good practice those
elements of good practice
for a good order committee so what we
usually
can what we have done in the past is try
to measure and evaluate the chemist
against that
it's a big document it goes from small
distance like itself like through to
noise counting so
maybe not everything is always
appropriate certainly good
um great starting point checklist really
to identify what you're doing well maybe
where your gaps are and what you might
want to improve
so we can certainly do an assessment or
start an assessment process
which we can bring back to this
community the members to look at and
then feed in
um have that meeting
thank you very much thank you rob
[Music]
i think otherwise um i'm happy with
what's down for community art
yes right and
now it's the time that we move
public so i'm going to move that the
publicly excluded
from the remainder of the meeting
because of the likely disclosure
of exempt information by virtue of
paragraph 3 part 1
and paragraph 10 part 2 of schedule 12a
of the local government act 1972
so i'm looking for a seconder
cancer craving got their first route
thank you i'll take a vote
all those in favor is unanimous
so we will now go to part two in public